hi my name is Amit Orin I'm the chief
executive officer of Eli's folding from
Turkey our company is a member of the
World Economic Forum for I guess 14
years I've been to Davos for all those
years and today we're in Vienna and
we're gonna talk about Europe in Central
Asia and I'm from Turkey and Turkey sits
right in the middle of everything and
Turkey is a growing country with a lot
of young people very innovative people
and Turkey is starting to export talent
to Europe Middle East and Central Asia
and I guess the question of how to
expand the frontiers of innovation is
pre-travel
turkey is lifting visa requirements with
many of its neighbors and expecting
Europe to waive the visa requirements
for free travel and turkeys turkey
deserves that in my opinion turkey is a
candidate for your membership for I
guess 50 years now which is a very long
period of waiting time but as long as
young people feel free to travel and
engage I think innovation innovation
that will follow through how about that
good thank you